[Musique]
c'est l'emblème de sudbury un gros cinq
sous qui surplombe la ville non pas en
hommage à la monnaie mais au nickel qui
la composent et c'est ça quand chasse à
l'homme a longtemps surnommé la ville du
nickel se brouiller son sous sol regorge
de minerais une richesse qui s'explique
par l'impact d'une météorite il y à plus
de 2 milliards d'animaux miennes sont
situées tout autour de l'impact de sa
durée ce n'est qu'à la fin du 19e siècle
que les premiers gisements sont
découverts à sudbury en est un gros bond
c'est vraiment l'eau qu'on est plusieurs
enquêtes qui ont déménagé à la
communauté
[Musique]
pendant des décennies ce dry profite de
son veau minier
mais au tournant des années 80 la ville
souffre de la chute du prix des métaux
même chose qu'en 2008 lorsque la
récession forcent la fermeture de
plusieurs mines
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le vent tourner de nouveau
pour ceux de rri avec une hausse marquée
du prix du nickel la tonne est passée
d'environ 18 1500 $ l'an dernier un peu
moins de trente quatre mille dollars
aujourd'hui le mois dernier un sommet de
100 mille dollars a même été atteint
lors d'un épisode de frénésie boursière
on peut pas augmenter la production d'un
claquement de doigts au contraire si la
guerre en ukraine qui derrière le pic le
plus récent selon cet expert la russie
durement sanctionné par l'occident
produit environ 10% du nickel mondiale
toute tension sur l'offre vient causait
des hausses de prix pratiquement
automatique ce n'est pas que la guerre
qui expliquent cette tendance à la
hausse la transition écologique aussi a
un rôle à jouer puisque l'unique élite
est essentielle à la production de
batteries de véhicules électriques
aujourd'hui on fait face ce nouveau défi
d'une augmentation de 50% de la demande
dans les quatre à cinq années qui
viennent et éventuellement probablement
un doublement ou plus de la demande
mondiale
une bonne nouvelle pour ce bruit ou
beaucoup d'emplois dépendent encore de
l'industrie minière les deux
multinationales présentes dans la région
ont déjà annoncé de nouveaux projets que
ce soit l'agrandissement de mines
existantes ou la réouverture du site
fermi
syndicaliste représente 700 mineurs du
grand sudbury pour lui aucun doute les
beaux jours sont à venir
dans la prochaine année on verra
beaucoup plus d'emplois dans les mines
prévoit-il le boom du nickel ne créera
pas du travail que dans les mines à
sudbury quelques 16 mai l'emploi dépend
des services indirectement liés à
l'industrie minière dans cette usine ont
construit de l'équipement spécialisé
pour automatiser certaines étapes du
processus de forage
avec une centaine de travailleurs
l'entreprise de hwange ségo coût est un
des principaux employeurs de sudbury
avec la hausse des prix du nickel les
affaires vont bien
même écho pour cet autre entreprise qui
fournit de l'équipement de haute
technologie à des mines partout dans le
monde y compris à sudbury
c'est bien d'être optimiste averti
michael mais ça ne peut pas être de
l'optimisme aveugle ou
car pour tirer profit de la demande
grandissante pour le nickel sln lui fera
face à des défis difficiles dans
augmenter rapidement la production
ouvrir une nouvelle mine coûte des
centaines de millions de dollars et
prend des années à cela s'ajoute le fait
que l'industrie minière est cyclique et
qu'une chute soudaine des prix peut
toujours survenir
c'est pourquoi la ville de sudbury
surveillent avec attention l'évolution
des prix du nickel la municipalité se
veut prudente et continue à miser sur la
diversification de son économie et même
des tensions crois qu'il ya de bonnes
raisons d'être optimistes des rêves
d'avenir de ce bruit est très prometteur
si on regarde le marché des véhicules
électriques une stèle
à un enthousiasme qu'on ressent partout
dans la ville comme dans ce pop qui
compte de nombreux mineurs parmi ces
habitués pour l'instant mathieu
st-pierre concède que le baume du nickel
ne s'est pas encore concrétisée dans sa
salle à manger y'a pas des mineurs qui
rentrent avec des centaines d'heures de
dollars d'argent pile ans quand ils
rentrent au restaurant mais le moral de
ses clients est définitivement ou rendez
vous un peu de confiance que l'emploi va
continuer tout le monde a plus de
confiance à dépenser un petit peu plus
sur des restos
la tente pour que ce bruit vous allez
retombées de cette ruée vers le nickel
pourrait être longue mais dans une belle
qu'à longtemps vécu au rythme des
soubresauts de l'industrie minière on ne
refuse pas les bonnes nouvelles et
encore moins les promesses de nouvel
eldorado